this is a production of Cornell
University
so I'm part oba oba church group babies
are very much interested in tomo
photogenic enjoying particular secondary
metabolism of this
group of organisms why this interest
well the main reason is because these
fungi are using biological control and
about control it's a kind of reverse
it's the opposite of the interested
parties usually head we would like to
know how to kill something better on
pathology the more interested in how to
protect planets kind of reverse that at
the end of the day what we both would
like to know is how our favorite always
works and what makes it violent or
dangerous or beneficial in our case so
these are just three
quotes when I would say about birth
control generally speaking we want to
something something it is more viewing
to control better our pests with like
why our Bible told agent to be more
resilient in the environment and to
avoid collateral damage so until what
you intend to do and also not to heal
uses this bathroom college like the
farmer some Bibles to lighting may
produce toxins
so i will stop talking to you about
before we are interested in in metairie
tremendous adjust to relate to you a
little bit this phylogenetic trees that
is describes and hypo creating play in
gradual are discrete or basically
intergenic fungi to be binding the three
major groups but what I would like you
to just focus besides these red plates
is that on top of here you find fusarium
jiggler trichoderma things foreigners
probably you're very well customers are
with also interesting is that if you see
or read you will see also some green
things here is the 12 steps and proclaim
basically these are relegated from John
they probably we're little pathogens and
they revert back to the plans either as
a bad pathogens or are n 25 abrasax in
some point in they there a lot of
resemblance to measure engine
Oh Jamie future so why do we focus on
these organs why measure your bedtime
these species and maturity strength is
one of the most studies into a
pathogenic fungi there are others but
this is for sure one that is the most
the highest interest is a generalized
and tomo pathogen one thing I forgot to
mention is that among these a common
pathogens with very some sort of special
specialization but many many times you
can see just a preference towards some
insects per Sofia this guy in facts
about several different species that was
reporting feature some are more
sensitive than others the sexual stage
it's it's known is very rarely observed
is called medical research never seen
just amateur on the way so we are
dealing with our basically Caligula cool
reproduction in
most of the cases and the molecular
basis of commitments will be explored
with know something about this guy but
not too much I think
so customary I should talk you about the
life cycle of matter whether in zoom how
this guy in fact it sauces and is a
lighter side of life cycle is really
simple it starts with the Canadian
landing on this little ferry plaza and
Germany in producing a person to a sorry
up to jump to contain an episode and a
penetration structure the penetration
structure goes through the cuticle in
such a beautiful insect scheme now a
difference between this cuticle and the
patio table is that this is really
really thick and his cellular and is
made mostly of proteins and kylee kross
swing many times with some phenols and
can be asked of us a shrimp so can you
read articles so its primary target the
primary target of the region is the
emissary cavity and Emily basic to the
insect blood when it reaches insect
blood it switches this is an ordinary
switch it changes from filamentous poop
yeast these yeast life forms are called
blasters groups and they disseminate
these fungus throughout the the mo
selling cavity it's almost works as a
blood infection doesn't charge it
you know any specific organ so it goes
to all being said and to put its
simplicity just killed me so sick they
kill if we don't know exactly how
basically when the insect is is that the
fungus out grows grows back outside on
the surface of the other events in
authority so you see these mummies
soybeans in case of the range of green
greens up their kind of losers and then
the cycle starts again now we have a
sequence the genome of these this
particular organism and what I'm going
to talk going to talk about you are just
too specific pieces of this
the entire story and particularly stewed
is to iron these two topics one is about
carbon source preference and talks into
that shifter and also there is something
about well this is an important topic
but I'm not going to touch about today
because it would require too much time
but it's the I point that I wouldn't
detection by the immune system is also
kind of important in we are looking at
it so just to show you something about
this this fungus you know this fungus is
this line is to tell me about fact that
this is just an average of amazingness
Geno
14 databases and has a number of gene
motorsport including models 4,400 and so
it's more or less when we expect me up
from our average assume I see now my
goal during our Goulding in this work is
to try to understand what makes what
makes me Tourism Authority what what is
difference with measurement without
furniture so to do these comparisons I
felt we felt that we need to have a
large panel of fungi to basically refer
to the order that the better here is the
list of for headphones i'm in for
bacteria and i use throughout the study
they have different lifestyles and
although this has to be taken with a
little bit of caution because many of
these fungi are yes ma'am halogen or
they can be opportunistic animal
pathogens something tomo pathogens show
in the physical abilities and so on so
this is a very rough but if you teach
now
if we look at the one way to represent
what's peculiar within a linear genome
is just to find a relative abundance of
some protein transit some functional
passes like protein carbohydrate acting
enzymes secondary metabolism and other
the just showing the relative abundance
like that as in this case mechanism is
significantly enriched in proteins
peptidases it's interesting in itself
but it doesn't tell the entire story
doesn't make you allowed to make any
company contrast and compare intel what
set this fungus apart if anything from
other ones is it just gene composition
and protein potential or the way these
proteins are regulated so we are going
to show to you it's something I a
technique it I'll be trying to use and
then suddenly I found when other people
are trying to so I was pleased and I was
on the right track it's the use of
principal component analysis to
reorganize this this
proteins and to try to correlate their
presence within lifestyle so principal
component analysis is just for people
don't know about it it's a way to reduce
the dimensionality of your problem you
start with discrete 29 dimension trying
to define lifestyle and principal
component mix up linear combination of
these variable and produces basically
what Apple Lincoln Bibles or components
that allows you to synthesize these very
complex complex problems in a manner
similar fashion the interpretation is
will be different that so we have the
destroyed nine protein classes have been
summarizing two components that horrible
explained sorry about sixty percent of
the entire viability so it's very very
explanatory what is remarkable is just
using PCA on those groups I should
before just as a relative abundance you
can see that for example the interval
pathogen tend to group thank you
to stay close together plant pathogen
than to be here these other side of the
pot and there are some animal pathogens
beasts so basically just dealing with
relative abundance or some protein
classes you can reorganize and describe
our unit lifestyle it's not perfect
because as I hope you also the our
classification with life studies is not
not it's very rough an alternative way
to these influences on the other side is
that before we cluster together we use
basically just the independent variable
to wear boating classes here using
hierarchical clustering analysis because
both we can cluster the variables but
also you can cluster see how the the the
effect clustering of the author of your
data set just you don't need to look too
careful in this you just look at there
is a dendrogram here in there are beds
basically where you can see that just
using rough rocks if occasionally
activities like resided address this
fungi can be grouped together a little
bit working pc
pathogens routier as they were before
this using PCA plot because they share
more or less same kind of remedy
composition of respondents here are most
of the non pathogens and some suburbs
here are our bacteria that completely
different we are almost out group there
is one ghetto pathogen year these are
always a little bit or enough of life
here there are some other pathogens so
it's a nice way to other glands tell
apart stuff tell apart species I was
quite an enormous to project now if you
go back if we get to analyze some
subgroups for example like I base and
microsite either if you were
underneath it look at the other and the
families within these larger group
travel light lists you can see that the
story repeat itself in the info
pathogens tend to again clusters
together and my pathogens are here even
more if you look at Y cosine other words
is this phenomenon is even more modern
if you look at polysaccharide active
enzymes analyzed using principal
component analysis you can see are
separated these species up here are the
bacteria yeasts I'm a pathogen and the
pathogen micro parasites non-pathogenic
suburbs what spits disguise
but even more explanatory is is the
alpha phase the other side of the
audacity can be conducted with
hierarchical clustering which you can
see also better how these fungi clusters
together when you use this main
glycoside hydrolases in the other type
of carbohydrate active enzyme as a
clustering right and you can just see
how this cluster organized in almost the
band's here how some bavaria sorry some
advantages are clustered together indeed
both miss some things here and they have
instead more something else that you
cannot treat because you have to work up
here in how the reverse is true for some
battle with navigator now here while as
expected the beasts are almost nothing
very little of hydro racism and the same
is for the animal
some fun so if we look in zooming and
try to understand what's more in what's
less without his holes here the discover
a very interesting thing that we could
not score just with enrichment analysis
is that most of the families that will
be missing in memory the end in other
internal academic finja belong to this
Blanco side otherwise family so you can
really do usually for the most part this
is a summary small but basically what's
missing there are enzymes carbohydrate
active ends up they degrade in cellulose
asst and pectins so and then I wonder is
that true does it have anything to do
with reality does it is really so bad
growing on these substrates and so if
you see the true can compare jeepers
Ella in Madrid in Reverse at one point
of relief as a big physical inspecting
is demethylated acting you can see how
the reading Robert after seven days Rose
relatively bad compared to the to the
growing on just Lucas just percent and
you can see the other cultures
coast is important to our classic 1%
same amount of Google's 1% Sophie barely
gross there's does why do all the same
on any several doses it doesn't grow
these are glucose mrs. Fisher I'm coming
out
that is now so that's one thing that
tells distinguishes meta resume and
other intelligence from the bulk of
fungi suburbs and special packages but
there is something that also they have
the other from Jerome head it's been
said over and over they are directional
very cheap activities and Kathleen's
which is true there are a lot of them
and they needed to penetrate to the
figurative or so for but also traveler
buyers how do those perfect it is a look
at it then is nothing technology and
also what is interesting is that just a
regression in travel Irma for example
this sort of patents have been shown not
to participate very much in my
capacities something else
what matter is IAM and some other metal
proteins have the Caliph enjoy visual
effect not home is this three classes
these basic release monomers from animal
carbohydrates particularly this is
interesting showing something about
these are single genes they have and
have a father from dragon tail but a
single gene can make a big difference
these seems to be acquired by result of
gene transfer because it's very similar
to some bacteria these are not sure this
is very similar to animal fully
surviving
why it's it's really interesting because
these are Auto Genesis counter in in
storing bacterial I know a deal
pathogens in particular in statistical
signal was another one a deletion of
single pl8 just knocks it down it's much
less violent and it's being shown that
these these enzymes basically facilitate
penetration asperities of these bacteria
and improvise also monitors from higher
numerate to the facility growth without
that enzyme loops like they don't very
well in connective tissues
so this was something I talk about what
metarhizium what's the preference of
many valid and infringed on regarding
carbohydrate with our very important
carbon source but one thing we would
like to know is how does memory to
protect infinitive without the
pathogenicity factor well I can tell me
that we don't know very much the egg
type we had insulted discuss to you now
and the framework here is a classic
paradigm that reminds the difference
that reminds the bio prof and microphone
seeing in one pathogen it's been said
that some a trauma pathogens are stealth
attackers so they penetrate they sit
there they are not recognized they grow
and then we are the biomass is too large
the basic in the insect eyes for
deletion now there is the kind of
shocking of the fungus penetrates and
immediately feels filter the host and
grow some sports
it's not sure what really happens but we
know this problem solving in between one
remarkable things that the genome tells
us is that is genomes are enriched in
very well in hallmarks of bacterial
toxins usually these bacterial toxins
but the autopsy swallow means I'm a
pathogen material ever I'm apart usually
they are not married we are Mookie they
have multiple servings what we're
finding in in in intro pathogens are
just some of the students it's not
really clear what the role is or what
their action in functions but is
remarkable to see this maybe in all
these tools so their survivability of
toxins low but significant and as I said
before most cases only some of these
subunits are found
just leave you break down our summary of
what these stocks in do in insect sorry
in bacteria you can see a plethora of
really nasty things like a call about
introductions value family in vibrio
cholerae in Kigali pertussis toxin is
anymore suppressant hysteria tock seng
also is a nice not very nice toxic and
then there is both Botox we will see you
know toxic they basically inhibit the
release of acetylcholine and other ones
so they are there nobody is
characterized them yet they are
particularly present in a pathogen if
you look at their distribution then
something kind of interesting that I
said before they are typical of this
engine apologies but if you look
carefully there are something July they
are completely devoid of them but some
like my auto even Cobra elbows sometimes
they had one or two copies of some of
them in snow no but we don't bother jack
and mater them and sound in their
composition assessment is not the same
for all and more positive what is
present in Bavaria place will be less
present in magnitude vice versa if you
look at the expression we have some
transcriptome data and the expression
these toxins inside the big are the
organism insect also we see the Sun are
up-regulated compared to compared to the
axilla culture they tend to be much
lower
express the ball one particular specific
arterial my toxin has been recently
characterized in a decoy this is very
similar to instep toxins and when it's
been expressed overexpressed in bacteria
in fact to inject anything it's was
demonstrating these toxic and as an
insecticide
but as I said before what one of the
things we are interesting the most in
this fungi is second life metabones thus
the same time metabolism aid a role in
emergency ambulance well I go back in
time a little bit and tell you that
until relatively recently this
particular compound is fractionator
dramas no rivals or money the
synthesized peptide was considered
detoxing of little better engine and
Sophie why it's been known for many many
years it's maddening secta Seidel it's
produced by some strain in in vitro in
our sometimes large a lot in large
amounts and is in correlated to the
preference of the of the other
pathogen which means that usually insect
there are more sensitive to destruction
and be sure to be even more sensitive to
the focus so this is the toxin well we
have characterized knocked out the genes
for synthesis the exhibit is all these
three three these three compartments
basic to be a minor students for which
one event in and basically none of them
made any difference in the interference
they are as us spirit and say as why
can't we be okay
difference at all but I wrote again
going back to medieval what we know is
that the system this is really loaded
with cellular metabolic pathways it's as
many TKS hydrates and arrivals or
peptide synthesis and in Turpan
mercenary jeans so there's we are a long
way to go while the participation of
seminary my family Dwayne facets of the
other of the disease is true that many
many many of these paths we are and no
but memory also showed that there are
few of them the other is just to look at
tantalizing artists to known secondary
metabolites our waistline we forgot our
genetic dream plastic concepts there is
a gene concern is very severe Methodism
and this is this other
half way that is almost identical in
invincible a PR people in the disease
being characterized produces arm
tetracycline my confidence of the
antibacterial but for the rest it's
really difficult to make sense or what
they might be and also oops
these works
I know
this instant
Oh
thank you
so and if you compare the expression of
many of these a sample this Sigma V
thermal energy in vitro and in vivo you
can hardly spot a difference so this is
a time force of the expression of vast
majority of IPs and because nrps hybrids
in spa doctor and zeroed in the music
and so I'm caution between 24 hours of
the infection under 20 hours is not
inoculated control knock knock related
insect this is the gpna control just
received official word this is not
cuticle and here is in axenic culture
and in Canadian together without
litigation on from in Turkish Cairo harm
because the mountains in the forest
tends to be low but you can see whatever
is expressed in vivo is expressed in
vitro whatever is not express we was not
expressed in beach
so this is a little bit I tell you is
important for us because we like
secondary with confidence but there is
another way to quicken the a quick and
dirty way to add a rough idea or what
the secondary metabolism does and is the
deletion of this PBS so why baby Jesus
are required to activate basically the
most of the cellular metabolic genes and
outguess mpk SS not the terpenes and
without these genes the these proteins
are inactive because they cannot the
possible Antonin modification and the
installation domains in basically they
are there but they are not function so
once you remove the right part of a
transference
people your head is that all nrps and
because are not unsure also what you
have is rising up sort of a busy if you
put more emphasis that the fungus is not
able to synthesize lysine they don't
produce siderophores it does exactly for
the secondary market similar mechanisms
go and hear how is the big et-1 mutant
looks like this my type pigmented is
completely white that's still tilted the
knockout work so what happens then if
you look at these basic the mortality to
the survival in time of insect you're
going to be one time and this level of
inoculum you have that they seven thirty
five percent of the insect update with
if you are mutant there is almost no
mortality so people Newton's are nearly
non violent and since we do those
responses we can
assess the potency of the of the
altitude organisms what I mean is that
using those response you can calculate
how much energy we need to feel fifty
percent of the population in a rough
calculation tells for the wife Natalie
of Emilio Canadian 2002 Kiran for the
population in this particular condition
while for 451 mutant you need 25 times
as much so it's very much for taking you
need 25 times more canadia to theory to
get us a more town so in this
presentation I try to its present to you
information about memories you and
Oh
the genome tells us on inside survive
and what the villains factor especially
toxins can live including is that
modernity of Mercy is expandable
pressure of activates similar
metabolites and enzymes that allows it
to thrive on are not support it's very
less adapted surviving part the pictures
are surprised compared to other
photographers and then the secondary
metabolism it's required for
pathogenicity i forgot what is on the on
the corner on the slide is that also
what is characteristic of is the large
amount of bacteria like toxins for which
we don't carry any media or function in
anybody we did said I like to
acknowledge and thank people from my lab
and my unit and collaborators we talked
to any every work working in us and
special thanks women for the dead set
the questions this has been a production
of Cornell University on the web at
cornell edu